we're now going to move to a quick
little video and
shortly you will understand why you're
all here hello sunrise and happy
valentine's day i'm pete griffin
president and ceo of musicians on call
now you may be wondering why you were
brought together here today right we
know the past couple years have been
especially hard but we can't thank you
enough for staying strong through all of
it first you're going to be treated to a
styling session hosted by kendra scott
at your local las vegas store
and even better i've got a very special
guest to tell you all about it take it
away
hi caregivers at sunrise hospital it's
katy perry here
i just wanted to say thank you so so
much
for everything you've been doing and
have done and
we've taken notice
and musicians on call especially has
taken notice
and in the spirit of valentine's day we
wanted to send you some real love
and that love
actually is in the form of coming to see
me in las vegas
at my residency
play yeah you're gonna have a great time
you might even want to like maybe bring
an iv bag for afterwards
[Music]
[Applause]
it feels great
that's how it feels it feels so great
everybody at sunrise is a big family so
everybody has pulled together
to
make it work i love katy perry i'm
excited i'm super excited
i can't wait it's it's been challenging
but at the same time there's been a lot
of perseverance i'm excited
i'm dying to go to the katy perry
concert thank you katy perry thank you
kendra scott thank you katy perry thank
you kendra scott thank you katy perry
you